Good to know.
Okay.
I just let go of like half.
I think so.
Well I'm all nervous.
Tell us about your experience on dating apps.
Um,
a string of first dates and by dates I mean like grab a beer and then you kind
of talk a little bit,
start to ghost each other and then he's like the first one to watch me on
Instagram and that's it.
And then you never talk again.
It's weird going from a life of dating apps to it being in person.
So I'm a little nervous but like excited,
nervous.
Ooh,
I can hear that.
Sub dudes.
Oh God.
Okay.
Yeah,
no.
All right.
Again.
Oh sorry.
That was so awkward.
Okay.
You doesn't matter.
You are on a dating app and you would swipe and no,
please leave now.
Oh
No.
Okay.
I just let go of like half of you.
So
fuck dude,
dude,
Dude Morin.
Hi.
Nice to meet you.
Hi,
I'm Lauren.
Do I start immediately?
Nice to meet you.
So what do you do for a living?
What do you do?
And in the military.
Medical.
Cool.
Awesome.
Are you not from around here?
Not Do I.
Do I give off that vibe?
No,
I just,
I just feel it.
Kindy acts,
I just tiny,
tiny accent.
So what is it doing?
Ohio state?
No,
we have the rock and roll hall of fame.
We got you.
It sounds really boring,
right?
Sorry.
Should I say it with a smile?
It's got the rock and roll hall of fame.
You were kind of funny earlier and like half circle.
My sense of humor as a defense mechanism.
The to help you wanted your kids to make varsity.
Yes.
Now my kids will be athletes,
packer,
Fan,
patriots and we're playing each other tonight.
Tonight.
I love the office.
If that's a hobby,
um,
church,
I noticed your cross.
I'm still trying to look for a church right now since I'm like,
you're chopping fine drones is what I'm doing.
Race drones from freestyle.
Then,
um,
yesterday I was just had to race in the competition for it.
I have a son who's 18 months.
I mean I kinda got catfished ones,
but like by a completely different person or they just didn't look the same.
She just nothing like her,
like her pictures.
I don't know what climate these girls,
girls,
it's filters magicians and like really into movies.
Like I'm a community like acting.
That's awesome.
Okay.
This is important.
Top three movies though.
Network.
Okay.
Independence Day.
Lion Ching.
Okay.
Those are three completely.
Gotcha.
They're very connected flanking.
It was nice to meet you.
It was really nice.
Was Nice to meet you.
It was nice to meet you
too tall.
Crazy though,
regardless of who I talked to it was,
there was always something in common that was really cool.
Follow up with um,
right.
Don't think so.
Is that bad?
No.
Um,
I think I had really enjoyed them all as people and I,
I picked them all because I do find some part of them attractive,
but I just didn't feel like that all around connection that I was hoping for.
I think I need to put myself out there more.
I think I'm more of the person that's like,
I'm too busy.
Let's wait till it happens.
So maybe that's something I need to do.
It'll just be less of a priority using apps and more of like inner actions with
people.
So I'm just going to lay off the apps for a little bit because even in person
that was hard,
like that was rough.
Thank you.
Oh Man.
Okay.